So, we started this course by exploring X Code.
In lesson 2, we learned how to add different visual elements to our app.
Things like buttons, images and label.
We also learned, how to control or manipulate them, using Actions and outlets.
In this lesson, lesson three, we will accomplish, three main things.
We will learn how to play, audio from our app.
We will also tinker with the speed of the audio,
to make it play really fast or really slowly.
And finally, we will also figure out how to navigate between
different screens of our app.
The next lesson, will be all about recording audio and
adding effects like chipmunk and Darth Vader